and let me introduce again
okay hi everyone we are doing some open
language design discussion about
uh well today it's about lazy lists and
this is part of a series of meetings
that we're going to be having about uh
various kinds of large-scale framework
updates that or innovations that we're
looking at and so this is one of them
okay Roman go ahead
tell us about it okay so the history of
lazy lists
is quite old so I started at the first
study of lazy structures then Leonid
made a big old big package which has a
different emphasis on different aspect
of laziness which we'll also talk about
today and the latest one that sparked
this discussion was a recent series of
presentations by by Nick or in the
multi-computation meetings about
laziness
and so the goal after that meeting
series was to propose to support lazy
lists as first class objects that as
much as possible will behave like lists
yep and so lazy lists are obviously the
idea is that elements need not be
manifest they can be infinite they can
reside out of core yeah I mean we've
made some progress on what this should
look like so let's yeah guys okay
so the implementation is all contained
in that single notebook so it is
obviously prototype so it will not look
as nice I mean Nick has some very nice
formatting for these things which we
certainly will reuse if we decide to go
ahead and so the current idea is to have
a head twice for the Constructor
and then map will just work for lazy
lists as it does for ordinary list
select works the same way take that
something we need to discuss today with
a tape should return an ordinary list or
lazy list and obviously part will also
work now there isn't a single
implementation that will fit all
purposes and that's why the main
part of The Proposal is an interface
that means that everything that
satisfies that interface
will be a valid laser list that can work
in this same way so here's an example of
a cached version of the list Blacklist
and obviously the
advantage of case caching is if you
access the same element again then it
will be instantaneous because it only
produces it once I mean that otherwise
these immutable versions of lazy lists
always suffer from repeated
recomputation of things so so the main
types of laziness that we want to cover
in this with this General interface is
runtime laziness so essentially means
the kind of list black thing first test
where the rest is only computed when
needed there is a small design question
about whether even the first element
shouldn't be manifested when you create
a list and we certainly want to support
both of these types
the other type of laziness that Leonid
has worked on is out of core data or
data that doesn't even exist anywhere
because if you have a function that is
very fast to compute the data then they
really need to actually store the data
up front and even if you need it
multiple times it would be faster and
more efficient to actually compute you
don't even needed and obviously these
things can be combined and one of the
implementation details are the chunks
which make it much faster too
work with out-of-core data if you don't
have to access the disk for every single
element
so there's one oh thing when if you have
that kind of standard way of laziness
where the first element is Manifest and
here is an example where this might lead
to problems so if you if I take select
the even primes then obviously it works
at first except that I didn't defined my
primes up here
so here they are
so here so if I select even primes then
it will manifest the first element so if
you take the rest of that list which is
empty as we know but it will run into an
infinite Loop because there is no second
element so that's one thing that's a
consequence of the infinite and partial
function I don't understand what's wrong
with that no no I mean it's not wrong
it's just if you expect things like that
then you might want to go fully lazy
where you only compute the first element
when you actually need it but uh well I
don't understand I understand it's a
hack in this particular case then it
will return something as opposed to
returning nothing because there are no
additional even primes well if if you do
if you take the rest of a fully lazy
list that operation will not do anything
and so it will be instantaneous but
obviously we'll turn another lazy list
yeah a fully lazy list yes and only if
you then for example ask whether it is
empty would it then run into the same
infinitely well first so we're just
postponing the problem
right right so the question is and that
relates to your take comment as well is
you know by the time you're asking for
the 11th element of the list
you could say oh I don't know what that
is compute it later if you need it
but at some point things are going to
have to be computed and arguably there
should be a function that you know like
normal so to speak that just says that
Nails you know hey you know uh is it
yes and I mean we look at the the set of
functions supported by lazy list and
obviously something like first or part
is something that better deliver without
right I mean otherwise I mean why do we
do it if you don't actually need it so I
mean that that was kind of yeah but this
is your argument here I mean in in no I
mean the question is I mean here for
example no no it's slightly different
because when I asked for the rest of the
list
if it didn't insist on producing the
first element of the West it would have
worked
you know right I mean the basic point is
that the the things that cause it to to
be actually computed are basically
indexing and and take right now although
I I would kind of argue that takes
should probably return another lazy list
and you should use normal to yeah to
manifest it but yeah this was a
discussion point exactly for this reason
Christopher for us to discuss later
about the take operation
yeah okay all right keep going okay so
now the main design
questions that came up about how to
produce how to represent the
constructors
and there are several ways one we call
something lisp it's totally confusing I
mean we should call it you know lisp has
had many implementations and it had
you know there were all kinds of things
it's not a good name okay in any case
that's just a minor Point okay I mean
that that's just one of the aliases of
that particular Constructor which okay
okay I mean it has an official name
which okay so so the
one proposal is is this head stress so
if you and for each of the volume
language generators that lend themselves
which ones are they which ones are they
okay there there will be at least later
on
okay so but I mean it's another one of
these things of of poke it and see if it
sings yes we discussed this with uh
Paradise now my original proposal was in
indeed something like lazy of range of
amount comma in infinity and that is
similar to the paralyze and that
actually suffers from that problem but
here we can easily produce Auto
completion on the first argument and say
tax coloring
yeah and it's not not only this but also
some of these functions when we take
lazy versions of them they might take
additional options to tune them which
usually functions like range just simply
don't take
yeah
if we put the options in here
but uh
oh yeah and there yes you can't put them
there
right you can't put them there a lot of
things will break yes I mean the other
okay switch addresses some of these
issues which would be
symbols for each separate symbols but it
depends on how many functions there are
I mean yeah
right in the case of parallelism yes it
is it says that there are about 20 there
and so
I mean yes I mean okay I mean it is both
both of these cases are possible and
that maybe probably never agree on on
exactly what they're doing okay hold on
hold on hold on okay you've got a
pattern here I mean let's imagine that
we had a parallelized headdress
okay and that we just put those
functions inside a parallelized
headdress and syntax color them yes okay
then
you know with appropriate documentation
links and so on
um
yes I mean it would especially if we
decide on something like that here then
it will make sense to have that to use
it I mean the question is what else
where else could we use the same kind of
idea these are these are kind of
modified versions of functions that
sometimes work I mean in a sense the
compiler can have I mean what is the
analog of this stuff in the compiler of
you know how do we know if there is a
um
kernel function version you know if you
say kernel function of blah does that
have the same issue
no because there's always a kernel
function of law
but maybe the other case and compile of
f for which F's
can it actually compile it well
to which functions okay this is the
question I mean go ahead
well guys all right I was just going to
mention one other case but it's it's not
very common it's like Buddhist stuff be
another one where yes by the way because
where your audio is breaking up again
okay hold on
yeah um
so Stephen anywhere where we want to
implement a subset of core Works
obviously it's relevant but that's why I
want to have a single pattern for how
this works I mean again for net function
that's another place where we've got the
same SU
right
anybody yeah this is but this is a
general thing to to basically convert a
warfarm language function into a kind of
interface that could have several
implementations
well yes but I mean my point is this
my point is this if we can make a
pattern for a
decorated function
that yes I mean essentially the okay
let's just think about this
these are yes you're right these are
different employees I mean parallelized
as a different implementation it's going
to give the same result as map you know
up to side effects but it's going to be
running on different machines lazy of
range is actually not going to give the
same result it's going to give a
different
I mean you know in a sense
we could have done this with sparse you
know we could have had something where
we say oh this is a function which has a
sparse form you know have a sparsified
wrapper but we didn't need to do that
because we have a spa Sarai spasaray I
mean and you know we have sponsori and
then I I see the but basic points
go ahead we only have one way of
creating sparse arrays or basically
right which is which is sparse array the
other functions like we have functions
like identity Matrix for example as a
way of creating a sparse array but it's
totally weird right you say identity
Matrix of n comma sparse array the
symbol right right I think that we
basically didn't have any idiom there
yeah right whereas we could have had an
idiom of a sponsified of identity Matrix
which would have generated so so we've
got two different things here we've got
the parallelized case where the answer
is going to be the same
but the operation is done differently
and we've got the other case where the
which is also what one would want you
know what won't imagine right compiled
case we've also got the case that the
thing is decorating that function and
saying I'm now going to give you a
different return type
which is in this family go ahead yeah I
just wanted to say that
um I think uh in simple cases we can get
away with not having a dresser and just
having like for sparse arrays and things
because spars arrays are essentially
very close to normal lists in terms of
what Luna there's a much crisper thing
to say here I think which is there is a
fallback for sparse arrays and it's very
clear what the fullback is
which is you just you just enumerate the
array densely
yeah right
so that's the question here in the case
of parallelism there is also a fallback
you just evaluate it sequentially
in the case of lazy lists
one of the questions is what's the
fallback and how costly is the fallback
and you know go ahead go ahead yeah I
just wanted to say that I think for the
case of laser lists fallback certainly
does exist it's a list but the cost is
in many cases will be very high
unacceptably high right exactly so
sparse arrays the cost could also be
high but
you know and that is a problem and and
you know we we you know if you have a
spouse array of like 10 million
you know that is a problem for some
reason that problem has not bitten us
too badly
but it might have done but it hasn't
um
now I mean there's another case which is
like the net function case where you
just can't get there from here if it's
my understanding Julio or somebody else
can speak to that in other words if if
that function is not supported in the
net another case here okay can we make a
list of these please that function is a
case another case is the database
functionality externalized database
functionality where if you ask what's
that net function yeah I think it's
called that are you running no well it's
not called that because we we wanted to
keep the name for when he had a proper
design and functionality what's it
called Now function layer okay because
it resolves to an area yeah
okay all right function layer okay so
okay the other case is database stuff
where
there is an operation that is going to
be able to be done and and again we've
got this sort of swirling confusion here
because we've got these operations that
are in a sense oh it's a select that you
can do
that actually does something in a
database
okay I mean this is
this is the part I I don't I mean
okay
again we need a a
that this thing where there is a sub
language that a particular kind of
execution
framework supports and how do we know
what that sub language is basically
am I making sense to people
yeah but in the pattern that you're
proposing here is that it is a headdress
with essentially syntax coloring that
determines whether
you know that tells you if that's a
supported function yes that's what
you're saying basically yeah not only
that still but also this allows you to
pass extra arguments which can be better
I know I got it I got it I got it yeah
right it's it's I I'm I'm just saying if
this is a pattern that is it's a
headdress where we answer the question
does it work with this function by
syntax coloring
I think that's a perfectly reasonable
thing but then we should do it
everywhere yeah I mean for me it's a
particular interest because I'm right
now in the finishing stages of my
iterator package where we have which is
uh immutable version of lazy lists where
I go on into exactly the same problem in
fact the arguments for lazy and Detroit
are almost almost the same so if we can
solve this problem and decide on
something like how do you use iterator
well it an iterator is also a form of a
lazy list but it is mutable so it is
very efficient if you just use the list
once likely if you want to do a search
over the list or select or map or
something
and the the semantics is almost the same
as these immutable lazy lists but the
immutable lazy lists play much nicer
with our language because the language
is based on immutability and so the
mutable cases like all these objects
with internal State touch somewhat
strange right yes
okay and by by mutable Roman means that
if you exhaust iterator once you have to
create a new one
you're trading through it it got to the
11th element in the iteration and it's
it records that state you do it again
it'll get to the 12th element in the
address yes yes exactly so it just
requires a different form of programming
but it is also a very useful concept and
I think we should have both
no it's fine but I I I'm sorry I'm
zooming out again okay I want to
understand
this thing that we've had trouble with
in the past okay of saying we've got a
function it supports a subset of the
language we've got a framework that
supports the subset of the language how
do we deal with that right so I would
like people to comment here on if we did
this approach of having a wrapper and
syntax coloring how that can be used
elsewhere
right so let's take the example of
identity Matrix and sparse array
okay
could we use something which is
okay come on we've got a lot of capable
people here can somebody please offer an
opinion about this okay so I think it's
sparse array the problem is partly that
there aren't a whole lot of of functions
that can return them I mean identity
Matrix is one but there aren't actually
that many
right so your point is that that so
that's a case where it's almost like
well then that's an option I mean I
could imagine other ones in um uh for
example The adjacency Matrix of a um uh
of a graph would be another example of
one that could be quite sparse
and right now it has some automatic way
of determining whether it should be
sparse
right normally the function decides on
whether the output is passed or not so I
know I know why do we need that argument
to explicitly tell you well
I guess I'm not quite clear which are
you proposing something like sparse uh
as a headdress for identity Matrix
exactly
yes well this yeah so for the linear
algebra stuff not only could that be
sparse but that could be some of these
these structured arrays as well right
yes that's a good point but I mean so
Rob I mean this is a good point and this
is why I'm bringing this up okay because
if we make a way of doing this a
framework for handling a sub language we
should use it everywhere
I agree yeah and so the sub language
you're describing is structured arrays
right but now the point there is that
that there are two cases of sub
languages the parallelized case where
the function is happily doing its thing
but there is a special case of the
function that has different
implementation that's one case the other
cases in which you are constructing a an
alien object like the lazy list case or
the structured array case
right so so two cases here one case is
it's a different implementation of an
existing function so the case that we
don't need is the case where you feed it
in Alien food
and
I said no the issue is this issue is
this
if you're going to feed an alien food
you don't know that it will eat it
in other words if if you've got a
structured array
and you give that structured array to
determinant for example
or you give it to flatten
how much do you need to know is flatten
going to work on that object or not
well for typically flatten will work by
you know expanding it out
well fine but but so in that case you've
got a fallback that is guaranteed to
work yeah and all the sparse and
structured stuff have fallbacks thank
you so so does lazy List have a fallback
just evaluate the thing yes I mean the
question is should the fallback be
automatic as in the case of spouse
arrays or shouldn't it be automatic
because
it will most likely I know I know a bad
idea right I mean so it's that this is
why we've got to catalog I mean held
functions are another example of a
similar kind of thing where it is a
um
or inactive for example is another if
you write that down please inactive is
another example where you know we've got
a headdress and you know anything can be
made inactive so that one has no doesn't
have a choice it doesn't have any um
um
give me some other examples of places
where we are uh where we want a sub
language and where in some cases we've
shied away from using a sub language
because we have no idea whether people
are going to know what's in it and
what's not in it Christopher mentioned
Cuda
um
well there was a I don't want to see if
we we didn't write it that the database
operation is another one if we need to
convert to a function to something that
we work somewhere else
yes
yes I mean and oh yeah was that yeah
neural networks databases every time we
have a like sort of a compilation thing
where we are not sure that we can uh we
can match what's happening outside
right but the question then is let's
look at the workflow with which people
want to use those things one approach to
the workflow is I write code that is
just standard top level code and then I
say hey let me give it a whirl to see if
I can parallelize it
okay speculatively now I have to say I
don't think people do that very much in
other words people have so little
confidence that parallelize will just
magically do something amazing that they
don't try it
yeah parallelize is by its name he
promises more than it delivers right
so so are you are you saying something
Stephen like something like we have this
inactivate that wraps an active heads
around certain things so are you
proposing something for paralyzation
where it would wrap paralyzed around
various things it's an interesting idea
the case of inactivate is Manifest meta
programming so to speak because you
actually get back the expression it's
got an actives sprayed around it in the
case of parallelize it is not manifest
meta programming it is meta programming
in the background because you don't see
it because all that happens is it
evaluates yes I mean currently the
current support for paralyzability is
much better served by this Paradigm
because there's a specific set of
functions
and the original idea and that's
something we can still do at some point
because we now have good tools for
passing uh the input and doing
Transformations on on the past three
would be a more General parallelization
function that would actually analyze
code and maybe find something and do
something right so let's look at these
patterns then so what you're saying is
parallelized
I mean you don't have any kind of
sort of parallelized list data structure
because you don't need it for some
reason
whereas I'm not completely obvious to me
why that isn't needed in other words the
return value of a parallelized of
um some let's say parallelized well
let's imagine it's paralyzed of range
okay
I mean in some world what's that yeah I
mean just trying to think yes
parallelize the range type it write it
down write it out I mean it's a
parallelized the range one could imagine
a world in which parallelized of range
would stick a number on different
processes
yes I mean at the moment you can
actually do it because it knows how to
symbolically dissect iterators and so it
is it doesn't actually expand them on
the master kernel but
and so it does some of that code
analysis already so if you have
paralyzed map of f comma range it
doesn't actually expand the range but it
dissects no okay fine so you're
explaining to me a reason why we could
have a just like you saying we have a
lazy list we could have a parallelized
list
well what would that be something like
but I would imagine that more as like a
like a distributed list like the result
of doing a parallelized range yeah
there's an object whose data is on 10
different servers that hasn't been sent
back to the master kernel so that's the
next thing you do on it I mean that's
the semantic multi-processing the OMP I
mean that's the the super computer type
parallelism which is is the word
distributed list please just type it no
no no no as a function
yeah distributed list
yes yes I mean that that would give us
some high level description of of some
future uh
symbolic symmetric uh Paradise symmetric
multi-processing but okay so so
distributed list like lazy list
is
a oh I see The Economist can't point he
had it will be distributed of lists not
rather than I mean in the case of lasers
there's two cases could you please write
them out on separate lines no no
distributed list is one thing
distributed list this one yes okay yes
and then the second thing is distributed
of list yes and that is the analog so in
the case of lazy list you guys are
saying there is a base object lazy list
which is not lazy of list
they could be but it isn't and what
you're proposing yes because we propose
the headdress for the operations rather
than but the actual the actual so in
this case again what would be imagined
is distributed list is the thing that
sits across many processes and
distributed of map for example might be
the thing that is the version of map
that operates see this is where we're
getting screw stuff okay because let me
go through this again okay
why do we want
this should work automatically right
just like with laser lists
uh well I think still and there are two
reasons why we may want the headrest for
the operations
one is that I wanted to describe what
the output is what is it constructing
that's one reason right
uh yes but also well that's the third
one then or maybe that's the first one
depends on how you prioritize them but
it also May uh kind of symbolize that
the semantics of for instance map may be
like normal map but in certain important
aspects it may differ
because of the nature of things we're
dealing with
what do you mean you mean differ as an
efficiency is different or what uh
differ as an efficiency different as in
uh say when what which things are
computed
uh or even if like you know mostly okay
but those are okay look we have many
functions with method options that
determine things much like what you're
describing
a method option though can't be a small
method tail wagging a giant you know
brontosaurus or something in other words
it shouldn't be the case that the method
tail causes the complete return type of
the function to change but the method
tail can be you know performance goal
Arrow quality blah blah blah you know I
some of those things I think validly can
change some of the evaluation semantics
yes exactly but they're just method
options they're not giant out in front
rappers
well frankly I don't know maybe others
would find more things about it but I
think my at least interpretation of this
headdress is that we wanted to introduce
it effectively to avoid probably
proliferation of new symbols exactly
So that's its main purpose you know yeah
right but I mean but if that's the case
okay
that's not okay that's not the only
purpose okay let's go through it again
right
one case is we've got a function like
range
and range could return
you know a sparse array it's not a very
interesting sparse level of sparseness a
lazy list a structured array a
distributed list all kinds of different
things that are different return types
okay
it could even return something that some
database thing blah blah blah
so one
pattern one model that we have
is distributed is taken
foreign
it's not a bad name for it it's not a
bad thing for that it's the Collision of
English okay go go back go back back to
this okay so the issue here is
hold on
okay
some things
can perfectly well be constructed
okay there are things like structured
rays and sparse arrays where you
actually don't want to do the
construction and then wrap it
for a graph for example you're perfectly
happy to construct all those edges and
then make it into a graph
in the case of esposa Ray or a lazy list
you
don't want to construct it explicitly
you only want to leave the symbolic
construction correct yes
and
so okay so if you can write this down
that would be very useful but I mean you
know one case where we need a headdress
is where we are taking a communal Garden
function like range and we have you know
and we are
we are
you know directing that communal Garden
function to produce a different type of
output
right so we're changing the output type
for a Constructor
yes that is exactly the case is that
where this whole discussion started
right right okay that's one example now
that's one use of this the other use of
this is when certain functions are
supported
on that
type
well okay the certain functions are
supported as the parallelized case the
parallelized case
that's the other thing
is
a you know okay which is to say change
the evaluation semantics of the function
you know
have a function with different
evaluation semantics yes different
evaluation operations
okay are there any other cases
well there is that other case which came
up with
with a lazy
take
off
lazy list right
uh take
currently returns a normal list and if
you want a lazy list then you could do
it like this all this there are also
strong arguments that take should by
itself return a lazy list okay hold on
hold on hold on that's case two here
that's case the case where we change the
evaluation semantics of a function I
think we change the output type
Roman yes I mean that's okay
it's kind of invisible I mean well not
completely I mean a packed array is
invisible but a spars array is not okay
I'm confused the two cases yes okay so
so take over the spouse erasers pass
away so take off a lazy list is another
lazy list yeah data set does the same
stuff I mean I kind of think that
there's an argument the take of a lazy
list should not be a non-lazy list yes
in yeah and just like with data set you
know you can get data set down to one
element and you still have to say normal
to you know plop that element out yeah I
mean in terms of design principle I
think take of lazy list returning a lazy
list is a good design principle I just
found
I never found a case where I actually
wanted to take to actually return a
laser list because the default argument
of take is just give me the first n
elements and then you really don't need
it just a practical purpose within
streaming I did find all the time
because for instance other laser
operations like transpose I explicitly
Implement using laser version of take
okay and uh in in that context if take
would return things eagerly that would
certainly be a very inconvenient thing
for for you know
for building more things on top of it
Kana has made another comment which is
about monitored which is another
thing which is again that's a case like
parallelized
that is
another web around the whole thing isn't
it no it isn't no it doesn't it's a
wraparound map for example okay another
case here is supplied
which is another example of where right
could you write these down please what
is this Supply is different
because supplied you don't say supplied
of of maps
right but the issue with supplied is
it's another one of these things where
um
where you don't know where there are
limited set of functions on which it
works
because that's what's concerning to me I
mean like monitored again they're
actually only a limited set of functions
where that makes sense I mean you you
can't really monitor it you know you
might be able to say monitored of fine
shortest path we might support that or
we might not
you see what I'm saying
yeah this is the general problem for
many of these that we will not have
accessible defaults like there's not
always the case like like it's past
array
yeah exactly but that's why the pattern
that we're trying to develop here is
if you know that it is a discovery
interface where you say monitored of the
thing and you say hey I want to I want
to monitor this thing and you know the
thing would turn some funny color you
know to turn you know I don't know what
yellow or brown or what who knows what
it is if there isn't a monitoring
capability
for that function then monitored of that
thing would you know would turn some
funny color
we could also introduce a single New Q
function that takes a symbol and one of
these headrests and it tells you if it
is true or false that is supported that
would be useful as well but I think
that's a different case because I think
that more of the time I mean I'm trying
to imagine yeah metadata right I mean we
we obviously have language metadatasets
which functions work with monitor with
parallelized with lazy and so on
yes that's fine but but my question is
as an actual user okay
let's say
that I've got a piece of code and I want
to monitor something I could speculate
that oh I wonder if fine shortage tour
is monitorable
okay I put it in my code I type it in uh
it turns a funny color it isn't
monitorable oh well
is that a thing one's actually going to
do or not like Echo for example you know
I routinely just sort of insert Echo at
in a piece of code and that's very
useful I know it's going to do something
am I making sense
I don't routinely put parallelize at
because I have no idea if it's going to
do something and it's all you know kind
of now if paralyzed if I were to put
parallelize you know of whatever and the
thing would turn funny colors that would
annotate I mean this is the same thing
I've been saying I mean this this is
this this is entirely doable right I
mean with and even with an auto
completion list and the syntax well I
mean there's even more than that Roman
if you say paralyzed of an expression
I could imagine that we've got that we
can you know in the user assistance
framework that we can actually go in and
um
um
you know essentially syntax color
automatically syntax yes I mean this is
actually on the table I mean and no not
parallel parallelized parallelize of yes
where is it okay
okay
no this is on the table because I mean
we discussed that in EC a couple of
weeks ago so
I assume there will be a meeting about
this at some point but
um well there's also there's also a
framework aspect to this because you
know so if if and we realize that
so so if parallelized is is is something
that that does something paralyzed of
map
um before that F list is evaluated
paralyzed of map is evaluated first
because heads are always evaluated first
so there's an evaluation being done
and presumably we can you know you could
you could optionally produce a message
if it's not if it if it doesn't work or
you could actually just convert
paralyzed of map to map yes if it's not
supported
but but okay some kind of warning
yeah I mean that already happens but
just for the other syntax but uh yes
clearly because we have a clear fallback
right which we don't have for some of
the other
well actually why not I mean but what
what would have what would it happen if
if I asked first pass away version of
something and there was no spouse away
code
there's there's two there's two possible
cases one we we say we've we warned that
there's no sparse array version of this
and we we do that or two we
we get the results and try and make an
as far so rape you know post yes it's
not an array itself it may not work
okay let's let's Okay so the main point
here is we've got a family of issues
around number one different output types
for Constructor number two changing the
evaluation semantics for a function
and it seems to me in the lazy case
that
the second one of these of changing
evaluation semantics is not what we're
really into here what we're really into
in the lazy case is purely changing the
output from a Constructor and that it's
always lazy to lazy and that that should
be our general principle like it's
sparse to sparse graph to graph data set
to data set
and that it always is the case that you
call normal in the end if you want to
reduce it to a normal expression
um
Lucas live stream is commenting that
that um in graph construction lazy
graphs will be a lovely thing to have
yeah well you see that's a good reason
to have that's a Constructor okay is a
question I mean okay hold on in this
proposal
you've got lazy lists
why aren't they lazy arrays why can't
they be multi-dimensional for example
oh why can't they be lazy trees they can
and this is exactly why lazy is going to
also be used here as a generic uh
Constructor no no no it's not a
Constructor then it's not a Constructor
we've got we've got to be clear look one
thing is
oh well maybe it is I okay what we were
distinguishing before sparse array
is
a head that represents the sparse array
okay it's not sparse of list of blah
right yep it's its own thing and what I
had understood here was that lazy list
in your design was in some sense a base
object that lazy of range produces yes
yes okay but so then an array okay so
what I'm asking is those base objects
that get produced is they're also a lazy
array and a lazy graph a lazy tree
or what because you can't get away with
saying no it's just lazy of tree yes
that's not going to cut it
okay it has to be a lazy a lazy each of
them because the semantics are so
different yeah yes I mean we discussed
this in the multi-computation meetings
and our feeling is that if we go for
full generality then this will never
happen because the lazy list case is
very useful by itself and it does not it
does not preempt any other lazy okay but
so here's a question for you guys okay
given a lazy wrapper for range
or a lazy wrapper for table for example
um how do I determine whether the thing
that I'm producing from lazy of table
is a lazy array or lazy list
did you see what I'm saying uh they what
do you mean by lazy away I mean the the
higher dimensional analog of a lazy list
with its own complicated semantics of
evaluation fronts and so on I mean by
the way I do think that a lazy array is
an interesting construct which I think
Will Reveal a bunch of things about
evaluation fronts which is the thing I
mean at the moment uh the only way to do
this would just be nested I mean the
elements of nest of lazy lists kind of
of course also be next I understand that
but I mean but that's not the question
right the question is whether there is
an unambiguous way
to specify I mean one way we could do is
to specify it via some kind of option
but that's bad because typically
functions should not return different
return types based on options exactly so
the point is that lazy here your concept
here has been lazy produces a lazy list
it it modifies the Constructor function
to produce a lazy list but now we've got
this horror of well actually there are a
lot of other lazy structures too
yes well I mean
oh sorry go ahead no I mean we we don't
have to cover everything in this
in the in this proposal I mean no I know
but we need a design lists are useful by
themselves and if we do it do it
correctly then this will not be
emptiness that's not the question right
lazy rapper around range or around table
what is it returning is it specifically
returning a lazy list or is it returning
any point yes right and rather
it's it's almost like we need the
headdress
I mean I suppose we could have something
where lazy defaults to returning a lazy
list if it can where lazy is a little
bit heuristic in what it returns it
Returns the obvious lazy structure but
inside lazy itself one of its arguments
is basically a forcing of what structure
to return
yeah so that's for the case of
multi-dimensional table test now I think
I understand yes
right so in that case there the question
is right
well but the problem is I think you want
it I think doing kind of magic automatic
stuff like that is can be bad if the
operations on the results might be
different right so if it's if you run
that and you don't know is it going to
return lazy list or lazy array object if
if your code like if if code expecting a
lazy list will fail on lazy array then I
don't think you want it to to flip-flop
like that right I agree
better just to say lazy list or lazy
array when you make it
well quite but but we've now had we've
now got two uses we've now got a
segregated headdress for lazy list and
lazy array and that's weird
but then we would need it why is that
weird well we need it we need both a
headdress form and a the object form
right we've got lazy list no I don't
think that's going to work sorry I don't
understand exactly why
so so okay so I guess the argument is
that you know if we had a sparsified you
wouldn't say sparse array of range of
blah you would say
sparserayophide or something like that
of uh of range of law is that is that
kind of the argument that's what I'm
saying I'm saying that if we've got to
segregate the rapper so what you're
doing there Roman it doesn't make a lot
of sense to me because lazy list is the
is the constructed yes but I mean I was
just trying to disambiguate if if there
are I know yeah that's what if lazy is
too General then then we could use lazy
list to say give me a one-dimensional
lazy list no we can't because lazy list
is itself that is not the same thing
that that is a you know it will be
called The Lazy list operator to type in
lazy list operator there okay it's
probably not actually ambiguous you
probably could make it no no it's I mean
it could work because I mean the lazy
amazing just like Association which is
its own Constructor oh or another
version would be to have a first
argument of lazy always be the type like
list and then the other things
yeah but then if you're doing everything
it's going to be quite accurate let's
just type it as a single thing lazy list
operator with a capital O okay that's a
lazy list operator of table
no operators will be in this it'll only
be Constructors
now of course there's another another
way it's actually yeah instead of
operator there right right okay yes now
there's another way to dis figure it and
that is because
if I mean the the default or the
standard implementation of lazil is just
supports one-dimensional ones so you
would have to use a different what we
call a back end or different
implementation which could support
multi-dimensional lazy lists sure but
Christopher's point is it better not be
the case that if you diddle with the
options there that you turn it from
something that the outer functions
around this thing can eat it to ones
where it's poisonous
well the the functions that operate and
they switch on the on the type of the of
the argument so if you provide an
implementation of multi-dimensional lazy
lists then you also need to provide your
versions of all the functions like map
and select and so on
no but I don't know but then you just
blew up the whole idea right because
because the whole point here is you're
not going to be able to provide every
single function in the system right
what's it going to do if you say
determinant of a lazy list
What's it gonna do what what should the
system do in that case
well it should it should just give an
error message because I mean that's not
okay but how do you discover that's the
exact problem we're talking about how do
you discover you know pecking at things
oh can I make this can I do a you know a
subset map on this will it stay lazy or
not
right that's the problem what we're
having yes that's why paralyze fails is
because you have no idea what's going to
work and what's not going to work
and in the case of laziness you know if
you're trying to write a piece of code
and you've got to you know you've got to
run the code every time say oh did this
work does not work that's the problem we
have with the compiler it's and it's
disastrous you've got to know as you
type the code is it going to work
I mean better that you have a simple
cognitive model that tells you in
advance whether it's going to work or
not
uh but still and there are two problems
here that we are trying to solve at the
same time one is whether this address
idea can help with this sort of uh
discovery of things
uh in addition to other things and the
second is what what happens if you have
several objects that can be potentially
produced and you need to somehow
distinguish which one is going that is
going to be
right
but I mean in for the for the question
of which operations are supported I mean
we have the same problem for for
standard lists I mean if you take
transpose and it's not the rectangular
list it will just produce a message
there's no way to discover that up front
and so each data type as just like data
set data set has a number of operations
that work on it others don't you're not
you don't know up front whether it works
or not I think that's that's a general
problem each I know that comes with a
set of functions I understand it so I'm
saying right that's a problem which I
consider to be fairly devastating for
some of these situations
yeah you know and and I really would
like to have something where
the interface is such that we can syntax
color at the moment of typing so you
already know whether it's going to work
just like imagine you're trying to write
a piece of code that's compilable and
it's syntax colors if you type in the
function you know I don't know uh subset
map for example and it's syntax colors
saying I'm sorry that's not compilable
then at that moment you have some chance
to say I'm going to rewrite my code in a
different way by the time you finish
writing it and you built it all around
subset map and then it says sorry I'm
sticking my tongue out it's not
compiling you're just annoyed
am I making sense yes but yeah but
here's a completely different idea what
what if and and it's not as tidy but
suppose you had
something like you know if you did
Constructor of table rule lazy list
and that was the headdress with the the
rule the thing the table is supposed to
return
yeah
I mean it's it's it's not as tidy but it
it solves that that problem of the type
specificity
I was actually going to suggest
something very similar but what how does
that relate to Christopher the compiler
when it has
a type specification
in a compiled thing what does that look
like
I mean it says typed of blah blah
doesn't it to represent a functions
yeah yeah
I mean yes you use you can use type or
now you just type hint if you want to
tell it you know some object in the
middle of your code has a type
next
I mean it's a little weird but I agree
that this is
you know fine-grained control over over
types of Constructors so I mean one
possibility is that lazy just sort of
yeah
let me make a comment here I mean this
is this is one of these design judgment
things which is always difficult when
you know in a case where we don't really
have experience with it like your famous
one I was just writing about yesterday
whenever it was is the x equals X Plus
One Design decision
right
people said you know back in 1979 1980
about SMP people said this system is
theoretically impossible it'll never
work
you know people will run into x equals X
plus one all the time it'll blow up all
over the place and nothing will work
turns out that was wrong turns out x
equals X Plus 1 is a corner case that
isn't important
so the thing that I don't know here is
let's imagine that we have lazy and that
it sort of just does the obvious thing
with you know as a headdress of a
function is that going to be good enough
or is it going to be you know are the
corner cases of where you don't know
whether lazy is going to return the lazy
array or a lazy list are those obscure
and nobody will run into them another
famous example is up values the fact
that up values are only one level
there's another thing where it's like
that could be yes we do run into trouble
with that but it isn't a front and
center blaring this is unusable type
thing
remember making sense
and so the question here is what is this
case is this case a case where most of
the time you know it'll be okay to just
say lazy of the thing
or you know and maybe the right answer
is
that
we you know most of the time you just
say lazy of the thing and it'll because
let's imagine that it's a graph that
you're constructing you know you say
lazy of graph what is it going to do
other than make some kind of lazy graph
am I making sense yeah and I would also
argue this the lazy list case the
one-dimensional lazy list case is by far
the most important
and the lazy away and multi-dimensional
and stuff like that is that's the corner
case yes but on the other hand in terms
of the you know the the
um uh how they say uh for the design to
be consistent
uh we don't want Randomness like
sometimes this is this sometimes this is
that
so we really want I think some clarity
that this is a very clear what is going
to be what it was going to speak and if
if we have syntax coloring okay or or
some syntax highlighting thing you know
and you say lazy of table and it kind of
flashes up a thing that says lazy list
or something somewhere then we kind of
know what's happening
and how would we create lazy array in
that case
Well we'd have to say lazy of table
Arrow lazy array or something okay I'll
just mention until we introduce packed
arrays and an array
when Wolfram was always a list of lists
of lists
so
so why isn't a lazy array just a lazy
yes with some sort of Dimension yeah
okay it's more complicated because
there's an evaluation front you don't
know where the evaluation front is
yeah but you can still have that with
lazy lists of lazy lists I think it's
more just an efficiency thing you could
yes you could but the whole point of
laziness in a not you know the
non-trivial point of laziness in an
array setting or a graph setting I
hadn't really thought about lazy array
lazy array is a simpler case than the
lazy graph case than lazy evaluation of
a graph
it's a special case of that
okay
but actually I would argue that the The
Lazy array I mean right I mean the few
times like for example the summer school
and things that we've had people do lazy
arrays the useful lazy array is much
more of a linear algebra object it's
like something where you give it an
equation for for you know each element
you say oh given this is the index this
is what the elements should contain
which is you know which I think that
would be the useful lazy array which
would have totally different semantics I
agree that we can actually do with a
structured structured array type of
thing too
has its own uses that we've discussed at
length in multi-computation yes I now
think we should be clear
in the Constructor that's where you have
to make up your mind what you want right
and so having
a Constructor which clearly indicates
the type of operation like this is
preferable to just lazy which is too I
don't agree with you I don't agree
because I think people are gonna have to
type it all the time
and
I think I'm getting convinced that in
fact so long as there is feedback when
you enter the code that it's probably
okay because the 95 case is going to be
lazy lists
and the other case it's kind of when you
say lazy of graph you know what you're
going to get
I mean we could certainly have both I
mean this one would be the kind of
yeah the official version the official
version if you write the piece of code
that you want to sell so you better be
very specific but if you type something
into actively then you will be more than
happy then that the short version will
just give you what to expect this is
this is the beginning on this so then
the concept is lazy list in the current
in the current thing that we're planning
is the only object that comes out right
there's no other objects at the moment
yes okay fine so in the future there
might be lazy graph and so on but those
will come slowly just like graph and
tree and so on uh you know a slow to
come things because there's a lot of
baggage associated with them or a round
or something like that as a slow to come
new object
okay so fine so then I think we've got
an idea here how this works and so I
think the concept is that for the
constructors It's a lazy rapper and
it'll syntax color to tell you whether
it's actually going to work you can have
all kinds of options and things uh
beyond that
okay let's let's go on in the few
minutes that we okay so the I mean here
is the kind of basic list of
Constructors I mean that the the set is
is small there are some other ones
especially the combinatorial generators
which are useful so we don't have to
look at the alternative for both of it
because we just discussed at that length
I would like to just mention the kind of
other conceptual idea the there's one
idea of hooking up external data sources
to Lazy lists like files databases that
would make them available with the same
user interface as
built-in lazy lists so that's another
thing that is part of the proposal and
then of course okay yes lazy
permutations I understand perfectly well
right and
I'm a little bit confused that lazy of
map indexed and things like that should
be things shouldn't they go back to the
previous page okay
where's
lazy map oh I know I see I see that that
I see the Constructor
map index is not the construction no no
no I understand I understand your point
here is
that
what makes this worth constructing is
something like range or table or Nest
list
where you give a number and it you know
generates a thing you know where you're
giving a number and it is coming out
with an instantiated thing with that
cardinality yes
right so it's it's sort of cardinality
and you might make a note of this it's
kind of the cases of relevance are
cardinality in these things here are
mostly cardinality in
and something out something big art yes
right now while list is an example of
something different from that that's not
a cardinality based function
that's more like a you know ordinal test
based function
are there not others of those yeah I
mean these these three are useful to
have but I mean they are just syntactic
sugar because you can always just start
with nest
no you can't not for nest Wireless Nest
Wireless you have no idea how long it's
going to go on and by the way Nest graph
as a I mean if we had lazy graphs Nest
craft or Nest wild graph basically is
the quintessential go on I mean that's
why our list is different from the other
ones here because Nest Wireless is of
unknown size
okay we need to talk about this again
yes but still on the way for lazy lists
at least uh this should be fine because
laser lists are not necessarily need to
know I understand that I I understand
that I'm just trying to understand what
functions are really part of this gaggle
of um
yeah we didn't intend to have a full
list they are rather Representatives
okay but but then okay let's talk about
read list okay because I consider that a
quite different
and by the way random real random
internship those are pretty complicated
because they have state information
you know yeah okay so they are examples
yes I mean these are these are stateful
so they would I see they would they
would normally normally I would suggest
to use the iterator interface and not
the lazy list but the two are actually
can become who can be the problem is you
can't get the millionth random integer
without knowing the previous random
integers yeah but that's true for most
lazy lists
not for range it isn't no not for range
but I mean for for select and uh okay
I've got another example here uh real
digits
is
yes integer digits yes
yes
well maybe integer digits as well but
real digits for sure real digits of pi
yes yes is is you know
lazy as could be so to speak yes no
that's a good project I wonder if there
are more functions like this I really
think we should shake this tree and make
sure we have all of them yeah we should
but I mean it's not the first thing we
need to do because I know we have a
proper design then we can but I want to
make sure that the design like for real
digits okay it will be lazy of real
digits and I think that would probably
work
and then you know like range for example
and it's lazy version lazy of rain lazy
range of infinity is going to just work
yes
range of Infinity on its own will will
give a message yes okay fine so let's go
now to the next page Okay so
so let's see on that I just wanted to
make a week okay so yeah
okay go go ahead I want to talk about
read list actually were you about to
talk about read list
uh partly yes I just wanted to say that
we have to distinguish between functions
which are essentially sequential and
functions which allow some kind of
random access indeed
indeed and sometimes it's complicated
like that it's a pie we thought they had
to be sequential but actually there's a
random access algorithm for them
similarly you know a lot of those
combinatorial generators the naive thing
is that they're sequential but in fact
there's a random access method for them
exactly and random access can be very
very useful if it's allowed if it's it's
possible Right but so some of these
things we might initially Implement them
sequentially I mean even for random
integer those probably a random access
for certain kinds of algorithms there is
a random access method there okay but
let's talk about read list because I
don't quite understand that one yet so
the issue is
you know to me import is the more
interesting function
because import
okay read list is a more low-level thing
let's talk about import okay let's say
you're importing
um still on we have an example or
exactly about this uh here in in the set
of examples where we're importing from a
file
but we are able to do that in a kind of
random access like way using seek using
seek essential yes pre-processing files
to first get certain positions of things
and then skipping records they only
basically read the part of your file we
are interested in okay I don't
understand the semantics so I mean let's
say you've got a thing in the outside
world okay let's take the most simple
example let's take get as an example
okay
can we have a lazy version of get
well with get as complicated because it
evaluates things as it reads them
all right well then let's say binary
deserialize
in other words what I'm saying is you've
stored in a file
or or here's an example uh yes this is a
better example lazy resource data
well with certain serialization formats
that should be possible no but let's
take lazy resource data as an example
you've got a big data set out there in
you know in the data Repository
but and you could just say gulp it all
in to memory but no I want it to be lazy
and I only want to you know only when
the evaluation requires a particular
thing to be read do I read it
yeah it's totally a totally fine idea
and actually even back in streaming I
had something similar and we would
certainly plan these kind of users here
right so let's just understand what that
is that that is a an out-of-core data
set basically
that will be for example an out-of-core
data set
or here's another example here's another
example for your collection images okay
with Dynamic image
um you know there is this idea of
yeah images videos all kinds of things
like that could be lazy too
oh you could have absolutely
yeah and in the sense the video
interface right now is sort of a lazy
interface
yeah that's the out of court type
laziness which is supported by leonid's
stream stream package so I think we we
can so I just want to understand what
there's a there's a thing where it is an
un
unwashed mess of you know let's say
binary data that represents you know
some Excel file or something that's in
binary form externally and you say I
want you know position a17 in that
that's a slightly different story
because that that that the laziness
transducer is more complicated in that
case
sure and actually here what in this
example d uh I'm using something very
very simple but of the same kind of type
because I uh basically you're specifying
a separator type and then it goes
through the binary data looks for the
separators and splits uh like
pre-processing things very in a very
quick way and then it figures out which
records are there like where are the
borders of those like you know and then
it can read sequentially or randomly
certain records only
right
well okay so so I mean just the basic
interface and we need to wrap this
meeting but but the basic interface to
this thing
is
there is a
what is the Constructor in our
can we scroll up
yeah and our kind of thing about
Constructors versus other things
is it the case that this is a lazy file
or is it a lazy of see this is what I'm
confused about uh uh Roman can you
switch to a different page where there
was this the next one
uh yeah no the next one the next slide
okay
we have here this proposal that you
basically have lazy list of something
and so basically that something can be
either file or something else and it's
lazy list that basically converts then I
understand but there's two possibilities
here one possibility will be lazy of
import maybe you can write that down
Roman lazy of import which is a
Constructor that returns something lazy
right that lazy of import I think is
directly analogous to Lazy of of range I
claim
foreign
not all but there's there's plenty of
formats that do have represent the
sequence of values right where this
makes sense yeah right okay
plenty no that that I mean import export
is
export as well right I mean exporting
from a lazy list in an efficient way or
so
that's less clear to me that's clear but
but lazy import is clearly a
constructor-based way to get laziness
yes okay now you've got a different idea
here which is you are holding and you're
holding a handle for example to a file
and you're saying rather than because
often with an external file
it isn't
naturally in an expression format you
know import tells you how to transduce
from whatever external format there is
to an expression format I mean there is
there's a useful case which translates
directly to laziness that is realist
okay you can specify what the things are
and I know but it's not a very widely
used function I mean importers are much
more widely used yes but the the quite
different thing would be something where
you actually you know produced like like
I've got many examples where I have
generated a gigabyte sized thing that is
a wolf and language expression I mean
okay here's another case this is lazy
and I don't quite know the semantics
here but it's basically a lazy Cloud
Expressions lazy yeah lazy
you know what does that look like yes
because the lazy Cloud expression
is something where it is an expression
but it isn't in memory and you only
lazily want to pull it into memory
or Cloud expressions are already lazy
aren't they kind of the way you access
them
yeah but there are no yes there are
there are two degrees of like two ways
you can do that you can for instance you
have a data source you can either
immediately convert it to something
which might still not be in memory but
already in some sort of dissected
converted form or you can even say no
just do it as sequentially as we need it
and that's why here I was using well we
were using this as a proposal it's we
don't know how to make it really the
good syntax here but you can have data
source or lazy data source so you can
have either data source which is kind of
immediately converted into something or
data source where you say no keep a
handle and just do things as you need it
I understand I understand you've got the
look that there's two cases here for
external stuff
I think you're basically saying this
one case says it's already an expression
binary serialization Cloud expression
you know whatever it is right
it's already an expression the other
case is there is transduction that has
to happen to make it an expression and
that transduction needs an additional
operation which is if I ask for the ten
thousandth element can you reverse
transcribe it so to speak to find out
where that is
yeah and it can be also a hybrid case
where basically imagine you have a file
you have a handle
and you construct a lazy list out of it
you've already read first a thousand
elements so that part is sort of already
in the form that can be consumed without
any further reference to that handle but
if you want to read more then you use
that handle and you sort of do the
proper unnecessary operations to fetch
another Thousand Ones
yeah I get it
all right we're making progress guys
let's please not wait too long maximum
of two weeks for another meeting
um well still we actually I think we are
ready to continue with this because we
have a bunch of other things in this
design which we didn't have time to
discuss today
okay fine well then set something up as
soon as possible well I mean I would
like to go over the pointing race today
but I mean the the thing we didn't get
to which will certainly also uh cause
some discussion is the set of functions
and special cases of functions on lazy
lists
well no I think that what we're agreeing
is that it's always lazy to Lazy nothing
resolves except normal well I mean there
obviously those functions that return a
single value like no no I'm sorry that
no it returns a lazy single value I see
I see your pointers wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait your point
is this which is what we haven't done
with dataset okay data set
even if it's a single value maybe it as
an exception for a single value the
issue is does it return a list if it
doesn't return a list you can't put a
lazy rapper you know you can't wrap it
in a lazy list if it's actually going to
if it's a determinant or something and
it's going to return a number you have
no choice but to return the raw thing
unlasified
right now with the way of access to Lazy
lists I mean it is really important to
understand whether a function just to
requires usually very
few elements of the lazy list to produce
a result or whether it is essentially a
loop the last normal that would consume
the whole lazy list so yeah that's so
yes this and also can you Roman can you
scroll a little bit up there is this
classification of operations now
actually it was almost there the the
other one below like uh the
classification depending on the uh like
eager eager lazy and terminal
non-terminal can you find that place it
was already on screen it was just partly
visible here so uh I don't know if still
we didn't discuss it today but there is
this classification which uh which I
think are important I think that's
sensible I see the first thing there you
know there's no choice now the only
issue is if there are new lazy data
structures that we introduce where
something that you say oh it just
returns a value right now the value it
returns oh it's going to return a graph
okay well we can't we don't have a lazy
graph so we have no choice but to return
a an eager graph but in the future it
might be able to return a lazy graph so
that's one issue there
probably a minor is Sue
uh we planned to use lazy keyword to
also force or maybe some other to force
the behavior
so if it's take or part or something
like that I understand that but that's a
different thing that that is a non
okay we've got more discussion today
sure sure can't do this right now unless
unless we move around a bunch of stuff
here which probably should we should
have an internal meeting first then yes
back okay all right absolutely this is
good this is making progress and um
you know I I think the main message here
is
um
uh you know there is more
um
you know there's a little bit more broad
thinking about what can be lazy like
resource data and so on all right we
should wrap up here thanks guys and see
you all another time